[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
monsieur nous procédons actuellement on
recense rendez qu'on va savoir
en ce qui vous concerne vous êtes qu'on
a écouté d'habitude c'est ma femme qui
s'occupe de chez sur la gérer
excusez moi c'est pas votre femme c'est
un de bourg et à quel coût
bonsoir est l'année de la femme il ya eu
l'année de l'enfant 1982 a été désigné
en lieux pour être l'année des cons je
trouve ce soir chez le professeur m'a
collé du char qui a été choisie en haut
lieu pour organiser pour superviser
cette année des cons alors tout d'abord
professeur merci de nous recevoir chez
je vous je vous en prie et alors
j'imagine que si vous savez été désigné
pour assumer cette lourde responsabilité
cette mission importante c'est que vous
devez êtes vous-même tricot il s'agirait
rien disons simplement que je suis un
vrai con sacrément con si vous préférez
la première question que tout le monde
se pose c'est comment
où sont les cons bien que votre question
ne soit pas particulièrement comme je
vais tâcher d'y répondre
voici la carte kono graphique de la
france qui nous montre assez clairement
la répartition géographique des cons
dans l'hexagone en rouge
vous voyez le département à forte
densité de cons en jaune les
départements à moyenne densité envers
les départements à cette densité kono
graphique si l'on compare cette carte à
celle de la répartition démographique
que constatons nous nous constatons
qu'en france c'est dans les départements
les plus peuplés qu'on rencontre le plus
de quotidiens qu'on peut dire qu'au
niveau de la spécificité isolement
d'ailleurs le conte n'est pas immuable
il n'est grave comme le montre cette
troisième carte nous voyons ici
la répartition kono graphique estivale
de la france n'était en effet les qu'on
rejoigne du littoral par hand très serré
s'agglutinent ainsi pour ne pas perdre
ne fût ce qu'un mois par an la
chaleureuse promiscuité de la ville ils
forment un conglomérat continue de
calais avantage est de port vendres à
nice audit alors qu'ils sont un peu con
sur les bras oui alors seconde question
que se posent tous les gens qui nous
regardent professeur m'a pris deux chars
c'est à quoi reconnaît-on les cons à sa
façon de s'habiller avant enfin disons
que c'est le meilleur moyen pour ne pas
se tromper
voyez comment lens caen ainsi quand on
doit précisément par c'est très simple
mettez dix personnes dans une pièce
observer les biens sur ces dix personnes
il y en a au moins une qui est habillé
comme les nouveaux c'est un conte est ce
qu'on peut faire ce qu'un conte
peut-être déconner fier je suis pour
ainsi dire impossible
même s'il est pris à temps à l'heure
actuelle si on est déçu à tout disons
qu'une fois sur cent il peut être traité
de quoi de qui de quoi
oui c'est un film effectivement à vous
entendre professeur dans l'impression
que cette année des cours s'annonce très
mira il ne faut pas mettre la charrue
avant les boeufs comme on dit chez nous
mais en effet je touche du bois ça me
semble pas mal parti quels sont les
grands événements qui vont marquer cette
année déco les événements habituels de
ce côté là nous n'avons pas changé grand
chose par rapport aux autres années où
tout s'est toujours très bien passé pour
nous nous leur connaissons c'est plutôt
sur le plan culturel que nous avons fait
un très gros effort puisque nous allons
inaugurer le musée des cons un musée
immense qui montrera toutes les oeuvres
réalisées par les cons depuis 20 ans
c'est énorme
oui on s'aperçoit que c'est considérable
bien plus qu'on ne pouvait le penser
et quel sera le prix d'entrée alors de
ces salles 500 francs pour les cons 10
pour les autres je ne vous cache pas que
nous espérons faire une belle recette
qui me sera d'ailleurs intégralement
remise pour être sûr qu'elles ne sont
pas intelligemment dépenses et où placer
ce qui serait trop con après tous les
efforts que de se fondre déployés pour
organiser cette année alors je crois
qu'on peut dire quand même progression
que tout a été prévu jusque dans le
moindre détail pour que cette année des
cons 281 2 soit une réussite
absolument totale sur tous les plans je
vous remercie du professeur m'a cueilli
du char
notamment il me reste plus là vous êtes
trop alors vraiment c'est l'année
[Musique]
et maintenant qu'il est sport elle est
légale
oui si c'est la grande surprise je
dirais même là la stupéfaction
personne ne s'y attendait pourtant c'est
arrivé jean bart en 6 l'homme le mieux
élevés du monde vient à l'instant de
perdre son titre je me trouve dans les
vestiaires du château de versailles
château de versailles nous vient de se
terminer la compétition
vous voyez jean berthon ci s'est assis
derrière moins marquée très entourée par
son épouse son entraîneur le duc de saxe
cobourg qui tente on s'en doute de
réconforter celui qui fut durant huit
années consécutives la mme lemieux
élevés du monde
pendant que jean berthon 6 récupère je
vous propose de revoir les principales
phases de cette grande compétition
tout avait pourtant bien commencé pour
l'homme le musée le légumier un très
applaudi dès son entrée sur la pelouse
j'en attends 6 comme à son habitude que
nous voulons de relaxation marque une
petite halte dans son coin comme il aime
le faire
le but de saxe combo lui fait un rapide
relaxine faciale madame woerth insiste
toujours là et puis burt 1,6 montrent
sur l'airé du 13 heures
regardez regardez la formidable
prestation du champion
cette manière de stemi api n'appartient
qu'à nous las mettre en place pour la
première épreuve baise main en fin
d'après midi
regardez regardez la très belle position
des mânes jean bertin cissé puis mais
que se passe-t-il
il semble qu'il y ait un incident oui le
duc de saxe cobourg monte sur le ring
ah oui ah oui il y as fils ilia fils
saxe cobourg oui parlementent avec le
président du jury vous voyez qui ne
semble pas vouloir pénaliser non
pourtant six intervient à son tour donc
le juge dit de continuer pourtant six
maîtrise cette contrariété et il reprend
sa magnifique attitude
il s'approche de l'italienne tina très
jolie beth mme qui semble satisfaire son
entraîneur et son épouse
maintenant ils s'approchent de la mangue
ou deux cas très beau poser de
l'invention index il va terminer sur le
landais skoda avec un business qu'il
conclue par un magnifique jeu terrière
du pied voilà les réactions de la salle
très chaleureux je vais maintenant avoir
ces notes 7,8 c'est excellent
cissé semblent satisfaits
or il obtient d'excellentes notes qui le
place en tête dès la première haie mais
c'est maintenant l'épreuve contenance
avec cigarettes et whisky et là vous
allez voir une erreur impardonnable de
l'anglais sunstone regard des erreurs
qui permet à jean d'or temps 6
d'effectuer un lâcher de fumée sans
faute c'est magnifique et ça te prend
l'eau dans une casserole c'est de façon
peut-être de l'appétit
l'anglais bien sûr et très déçue 7 9 7 9
s'est vraiment 9,7 même le juge romain
d'une excellente note
et maintenant ce sont les figures libres
je vous laisse regarder jean martin 6
comment allez vous
[Musique]
avec du repos non merci
juste un doigt le champagne délicieux la
soirée s'annonce douce et brillante la
lune s'est levé mais votre chien est
resté couché
[Musique]
il marie scan à partir du subjonctif à
moscou il eût fallu que juste
parfaitement exécuté comment va-t-il
terminé connu le russe pour prendre le
bus fera doux de touristes absolument
qu'elle maîtrise sa partenaire habituel
linda b la pénètre maintenant sur la
piste pour l'épreuve difficile dû tomber
de mouchoirs regardez un excellent
réflexe c'est très bien
et puis c'est l'épreuve fatidique du
repas en tête-à-tête regardez bien nous
en sommes nos fromages pourtant si c'est
assis face à son challenger le russe
coach qu'offrent les deux hommes sont
tendues à retourner de gulu bien exécuté
mais nerveux que chaque oeuf qui à 15
points de retard et crise mais les deux
hommes s'observent kocak kof a déjà fait
deux caches sur son plastron et puis
soudain c'est l'erreur la faute d'
incompréhensible regardez bien voilà
c'est fait jean bart ainsi sa coupe et
son fromage avec son goût de 1%
le russe se rient très peu sportivement
d'ailleurs et le ralenti nous le montre
c'est indiscutable jean berthon 6 ne
s'est pas encore rendu compte de sa
faute
cette fois ça y est il sait que pour lui
tout est fini et les russes de tchekhov
devient l'homme le mieux élevé du nombre
de 1990
jean bertrand 6 tout d'abord merci de
nous accorder cette interview sur steam
de la piste bon vous avez dominé la
compétition de bout en bout que s'est il
passé exactement
oui c'est vrai j'ai été très à l'aise
durant tout mon parcours mais cette fois
ci car sackhoff a été mieux avec moi
c'est tout que comptez vous faire
maintenant et à prendre quelques jours
de repos et puis il reprendre
l'entraînement le touché de fourchette
sur tout et et puis le baisemain un goût
pour les championnats africains
d'abidjan auquel je dois participer
quand partez-vous abidjan pour pardon
partez-vous pour abidjan
pardonnez-moi en février merci jean
merci et bon monsieur le duc on a dit
beaucoup on a écrit que vous aviez
surentraînés l'emportant 6 qu'en est il
exactement
tu feras mais c'est absolument inexact
j'ai préparé jean cette compétition
d'une façon tout à fait classique c'est
à dire eh bien il a fait 5 à 6 comme tel
par jour dont deux en ambassade
un week end à cannes alternaient avec un
week end à deauville pendant un mois
et bien sûr dans les dernières semaines
là où deux vernissages en haute montagne
et d'une façon intensive les sorties du
rsa passage à auteuil
comment expliquez vous cette défaillance
de l'homme le mieux et baies du monde
mais je ne les explique pas chers amis
je n'explique pas d'une certaine façon
elle honore car elles rappellent de ce
que l'on oublie trop souvent l'homme le
mieux élevés du monde est aussi un homme
merci monsieur le duc et pour madame pas
trop déçu d'être la femme du deuxième
homme le mieux élevés du monde
ben si ça fait chier non parce qu'on
sait tout de même qu'à celles émises
pendant des plombes à profit de la
décroche la timbale à la con je
comprends je comprends et bien c'est sur
cette image à la fois digne et
mélancolique que je vous rend l'antenne
à vous les studios
[Musique]
selon un sondage réalisé récemment à
johannesburg
il apparaît à l'évidence que dans leur
immense majorité les blancs et les noirs
d'afrique du sud sont contre le cancer
à l'issue de son entretien avec le pape
johnny c'est timo le couturier du tout
paris a donné une conférence de presse
de laquelle il ressort essentiellement
que sa sainteté est un petit 44
marseille 6 minutes d'arrêt ou peindre
marseille 7 minutes d'arrêt clermont
ferrand vidéo de rabot sur l'ensemble du
pays sauf au 138e mondial en semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel homme grand blond aux yeux bleus
sera mai mais un jour au coeur des
criques sauvages de la riviera au
printemps j'aime les préférences que ce
soit le mari de christiane l'accen
demeurant 14 rue nationale 06 la napoule
que j'ai rencontré dire que tel de
maradi louis là que pina josiane je suis
alsacien et j'en suis fier tout comme je
suis fier de faire partie du petit long
de ce qui aujourd'hui encore croix et
respecte les vraies valeurs
c'est un foyer que je veux fonder c'est
une famille que je veux construire femme
fardée et filles libertines abstenez
vous c'est une femme de tête et de peurs
responsable que je cherche n'importe
quelle femme de tête et de coeur
responsable du moment qu'elle ait de
gros seins et qu'elle met des porte
jarretelles tu à l'antenne
ici monique granville qui vous parle de
la maison d'arrêt de fleury en bière ici
c'était un peu d'affolement
il se passe quelque chose mais nous ne
savons pas exactement quoi vous voyez la
section des gardiens qui se prépare à
intervenir
nous espérons vous faire vivre en direct
qui je souhaite ne sera pas un incident
trop grave
nos caméras sont sur les lieux depuis
deux heures déjà à l'eau oui oui oui on
me signale que nous avons une caméra
prête au qg des gardiens à vous tirer
alors à londres où il s'emploie
éclatement graham directeur jeu
directeur pour la dernière fois élire au
nom de tous mes camarades et devant
l'inégalité des forces
faites un effort d'humanité renonçons
grange à benghazi vous avez vu d'autres
souvenez-vous 1,75
c'est le directeur ou 1,75 c'était une
révolte et j'ai mené mes hommes au
combat
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui j'ai peur c'est
ridicule grosjean tenez vous prêts
[Musique]
alors prenez jeu c'est trop dire
monsieur le directeur
grandjean s'élève à vous de jouer mais
monsieur acteurs connus
allez on y retourne duchamp brummel avec
moi merci monsieur directeur bonne année
bonne année ce soir nous vous souhaitons
bonne à dire nous vous promettons
beaucoup moins fort
nous avons eu tort
le passé mais non dits de la pop corn
ne voulais pas tomber
ah bon
j'vais la tige futur de là
toute cette année nous bien nous n' est
qu' on a des bonnes années
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui comment nourrir sans bien
des conneries par chance si tout va bien
si le temps le permet mon meilleur ami
devrait mourir d'un instant à l'autre
en effet vous allez voir c'est évident
que cet homme va mourir d'un instantané
voyez déjà comme le vin comme la vie
semble vouloir s'échapper de son pauvre
gars de l'échafaud mais on sent aussi
qu'il a envie de dire quelque chose
qu'il a envie de de prononcer une ultime
phrase
or il est très important de mourir sans
dire des cas afin que la veuve et la
postérité garde à tout jamais un
souvenir ému du cher disparu car mourir
sans dire des conneries c'est la seule
vraie différence entre l'homme et la
bête
asimo je meurs mais je quitte cette
vallée de larmes
le coeur serein à du vol exactement ce
qu'il faut pas faire c'est c'est nul
c'est nul je meurs sans ian ya une ligne
a lâché sur vous même n'êtes pas
capables de répéter ce qui est dit votre
mari avant de mourir maintenant parce
que j'étais faire pipi ans j'ai raté la
fin vous le fils du gouvernement
balladur
je m'en vais non je pars web en est
incapable
il faut donc à tout prix éviter les
platitudes moi je suis pas votre place
j'aurais dit quelque chose que quel
journal dimanche puisque paul est mort
oui j'aime bien j'aurais dit quelque
chose comme à mourir à dimanche
c'est un peut mourir deux fois c'est
julie marcel tant attendu fait comme le
monsieur mourir un dimanche c'est un
peut mourir deux fois deux fois par deux
fois mourir mais les visiteurs du monde
ou non d'un prochain entretien nous
verrons ensemble comment être la plus
belle à l'enterrement
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et à toutes vous venez
dans la cuisine des gestes lille alors
je suis qu'est ce que vous nous proposez
de beaux jours et bien bernard je vous
propose un lapin à la prussienne qui est
très agréable en hiver peu un heureux et
faciles à cuisiner je me régale déjà
alors il nous faut bernard 100 g de
farine
voilà vous 5 g de farine merci 2e 2e de
poule et deux vies 1,9 de cannes à vous
mélangez 2 oignons avec du miel ou
j'adore revenir à 6-6 bernard vous
incorporerez vue vous mélangez à votre
famille et à vos yeux
oui voila merci bernard métais petit peu
de vinaigre un petit peu de binaire oui
une demi livre de beurre et alors 300 g
de raisins secs et bien le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est tout ça me semble très
sympathique alors vous mélangez le tout
voilà oui merci bernard vous mélangez et
vous mettez dans une casserole place
vous mélangez bien
oui et vous laisser tranquillement
mijoter à feu doux
yamoo se sont déjà très bons échos telma
fois que votre plan de travail et
débarrassez vous sortez de votre
réfrigérateur votre belle tête de veau
bernard si vous voulez me la passer s'il
vous plaît tout de suite tous line c'est
ça oui
voila voila merci présente elle a bien
la caméra oui voilà
et tant que vous y êtes vous me donnez
le bo garenne qui est à côté si bernard
le magnifique il est très beau c'est un
lapin pour 6 personnes bien besoin de
votre tête de vous et vous la couper en
trois voilà vous essayer de bien
maintenir la cervelle au fond comme ceci
vous voyez bien n'a comme ceci voilà
et alors pour ceux qui n'ont pas de
passé à escargots comme celle ci que
vous devez utiliser vous pouvez utiliser
aussi à des à coudre car vous allez
enlever les yeux
voilà neuf voilà deux yeux est la langue
la langue si vous ne rêvez pas vous
pouvez même utiliser la main voilà
voulait préserver précieusement deux
côtés pour tout à l'heure je voulais pas
ce dernier tenait berne en outre il est
à la caméra montre et vers la caméra
très bien merci bernard bien une fois
votre tête coupée vous la payez en
pointe et vous savez pourquoi berlin
non mais si bernard essayé de miner set
facile c'est pour que votre lapin élèves
prussia non voilà comment va notre sauce
de mam nouveau mal mais remet la un
petit peu bernat ne faut pas que ça
attache vous l'a révélé un petit peu
tenez venez me maintenir le coût de cela
pas moi oui vous maintenez le court
voilà je vais couper en petits dés d'un
centimètre cube mais il faut le faire
très vite
le sommet de la tête ne se parlent pas
le vous irriter coupées et plus votre
plat en rade du tout menacé en malaxant
bien comme ceci vous voyez bernard et
puis vous faire si c'est votre tête de
veau avec rodez deuxième rang en tassant
bien en décembre atelier pas peur vous
tassez voilà c'est presque terminé et
maintenant la sauce de nîmes à la sauce
bernard je me brûle à vous verser la
sauce par dessus la sauce vision et les
yeux piquent les yeux vous décorez avec
la langue que vous piquer avec les idées
voilà
et voilà d'autres lapins halak ou sienne
à servir et à manger cru pour six ou
huit personnes prochaine
[Musique]
lille grâce aux efforts départementaux
pour le repeuplement de la faune
volatile on a pu observer hier plus de
15 vols de canards sauvages au dessus de
tourcoing coin coin coin coin c'est tout
non il voudrait faire une grimace
oui je veux bien
merci
[Musique]